bonjour madame j'ai bien cherché
c'est parfait c'est tout près voilà
premier client de la journée pour
mathieu musée dans son qu'à
rambouillet à 38 ans cet habitant de
bullion s'est lancé en juin dernier dans
le concept de la nourriture vegan des
recettes qui consiste à bannir les
produits d'origine animale pour réussir
son projet il n'a pas hésité à investir
près de 10000 euros
c'est un business qui est en train de
naître c'est une niche encore et voilà
donc c'est effectivement plus
intéressant
et plus rassurant aussi que de se dire
voilà je vais lancer un énième camion de
pizza
le restaurateur propose une carte qui
évoluent en fonction des saisons
aujourd'hui mathieu propose des wraps de
falafel des croquettes de pois chiches
là c'est 100% derrière n'y a absolument
aucune trace de deux produits d'origine
animale ne pas de l'ehpad of pas de
beurre une recette qui fonctionne ils
sont une vingtaine à venir chaque jour
devant son stand on n'hésite pas à en
parler autour de nous et c'est une
grande découverte pour certains j'ai des
amis qui ne sont pas mes gammes que gm
était dernièrement et qui sont vraiment
apprécié du début jusqu'à la fin
les plats donc si mathieu a pour projet
d'ouvrir un jour un restaurant vegan
dans les yvelines d'autres ont franchi
le pas c'est le cas de cet établissement
versailles et odette et tristan mon
genou ont été les précurseurs de la
cuisine végétalienne dans les yvelines
en ouvrant dès septembre 2015 on est
vraiment très content quand on est
ouvert on a on savait pas exactement à
quoi s'attendre
parce que ce type de ce type d'offre
existait pas on n'y croyait pour ce que
nous-mêmes on consommait sur notre
produit et on a tout de suite
une hotte notre clientèle à nous
[Musique]
et on a beaucoup d'habitués qui viennent
régulièrement de plus le développement
de la tendance végal les deux
trentenaires ont connu près de 20 % de
clients plus aujourd'hui ils servent 50
à 70 couverts par jour en semaine et
plus de 100 le week end la mode touche
même la gente masculine
au début ils venaient pas parce qu'ils
sentaient qu'ils n'avaient pas être
assez nourris ba aujourd'hui ces fonds
que plaisir et bien aujourd'hui on a des
tas de d4
ça c'est génial pour répondre à cette
hausse de la demande ces deux versets
vont même déménagé de leurs 30 mètres
carrés rue de sa tournée pour un
établissement deux fois plus grand dans
le même quartier